welcome to this video that's so moto to
cut sumo two cats emoto okay um yeah
let's stay with indy for territory for
is a good move of course but I'm it's
it's still a bit alien to me that's kind
of this kind of e for opening let's see
my age three line something else okay
hmm I wanted to try the Petrosian system
but does not seem to happen okay okay
let's see this early night a six instead
of e 5 is an interesting line like
delays e75 and sometimes it can even
play without it all together going with
them c6 first things like that yeah
Fisher page file I don't know if this is
well placed there to be honest I way we
can do that why not try to get my bishop
I mean trying us the wrong word he will
get it
very tricky don't really like it a lot
if you take such am the the dark squares
are very important to control Joe night
a six caught me a little bit of God yeah
and no he's striving to use the long
diagonal okay I mean what else is there
i cannot let him take or something like
that um I wonder
there's some way to use this vulnerable
annoyed 95-93 hg not working what would
be five maybe 593 3hh tags and this is
may be interesting 'if 593 hg3 de five
queen III attacking c5 Andy five and if
he wants to cover if I with Queen d6
there is 94 dropping c5 maybe I don't
want to just sit tight here this looks
wrong and need to do something active
okay g4 maybe I can go to edge form it's
not bad it's okay no matter how the H
file is opened yeah Queen III was my
idea and I still don't see a big
drawback to that if I can just take if
I've I should be alright I think maybe
e6 maybeee sexism that's it certainly
possible and try to know what
and 95 should be good yeah this knight
c6 them come on you be five really looks
some kind of out of this world it really
did not fit into the position at all
yeah so knight c6 now and 90 x is seven
or Bishop takes you four which is simple
and good let's go there M 94 94 is the
Queen going actually Queen just six
losses attitude oh come on play it first
and think later 95 night XD 690 xe3
night XD 7 check King goes and fe 3 with
an extra piece and this is probably one
of the better lines maybe you can click
windy seven maybe you can do that okay
the ante can take be too maybe you can
step up some trouble with the beep on
but it shouldn't be enough really for a
piece and there's tons of stuff hanging
on c8 and so on now what is she doing
now I was thinking about you cannot
sacrifice the Queen in this position you
really cannot what is one of those guys
who lets the clock run down no check
yeah I know just only three we should be
to this is what cost me slight concern
but how well I can take age 6 m this is
is quite convincing it I can take age 6
check check check let's see it says some
direct way to two made on or something
like that should yeah I don't have
really have a good Scoob air for this
would give one a little bit awkward
c 3 i'm not so easy not easy i can go
Bishop c4 pertaining rook g6 but
yeah this was my idea but it's just like
because I didn't see anything better
I have the important move 94 m this is
very very important otherwise it would
be tricky with rocky g8 and this is now
he has basically yeah misplaced his own
bishop here we should see two will
coordinate yeah this was still a bit
tricky with the Seaport
no it's really nothing nothing that it
can I'm perfectly coordinated now be
sure buoyancy to knight on d4 they
protect we night protect the bishop PS
no way forward and I can start to pick
up on him okay I didn't really like this
opening position very much to be totally
honest I'm warning Gavin you can invade
but I'm really nicely coordinated now
it's all protected
disconnected or something it sometimes
happens it's not like black for effects
on time and this is just some technical
glitch hmm yeah he defended this quite
resourceful around here I mean b5 i
think is really a little bit a little
bit much this move if we look at this i
mean the the probably critical is
something like Queen d6 when I was
thinking nitey forward it is it is not
clear at all i was thinking here come in
here and then go from go from here i
didn't i didn't really calculate it
further minutes blitz chess Quincy five
that's not bad for black this and then
f5 is really good for like actually yeah
maybe this idea wasn't great a b5 is
this really assistance is asking too
much I guess Queen here right here I
still I wasn't totally sure after Queen
d7 what I should do because taking us no
not that great this is this is less
convincing him I'm not winning check I'm
not winning as much material him into
this and I didn't calculate it did it
look weird to me I was actually thinking
that if he if he goes back which was a
bit unlikely yeah because he could have
gone here in the first place I can't go
i can take this young and he cannot grab
check cause of the fork means that well
i have old stuff and play now maybe I
can just castle long and then attack
Yuma I'm a porn app c5 hangs yeah it's
probably it's probably good young yeah
and in the game let's just I just want
to check chiefly if check this was right
check check 123 Bishop e3 are they i
have no i mean i was tempted to think
about those kind of things with roopa g6
but see to I have know who I cannot give
love in the new queen ER okay but it was
there it was alright getting it to see
two and I to d4 and why this why this
winning okay thanks for watching